es ist ein durchbruch für astronomie
teams weltweit mit der hilfe des
spektrographen news ist es fachleuten
gelungen die kosmischen filamente im
jungen universum zu kartieren
die aktuellen aufnahmen übertrumpfen
sogar die aufnahmen des hubble teleskops
das bislang die am tiefsten reichenden
bilder des kostenlos geliefert hatte
dieser blick auf das kosmische netz
erlaubt eine spektakuläre zeitreise in
die anfänge des universums klicks um
science in future
hier gibt es drei mal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasste nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
die materie im all verteilt als eine art
netzwerk fahrten förmiger gas strukturen
und knotenpunkte diese sogenannten
filamente gelten als die geburtsorte der
galaxien zudem enthalten sie auch den
großteil der dort existierenden
wasserstoffatome diese sind nach ansicht
der wissenschaft höchstwahrscheinlich
schon sehr früh nach dem urknall
entstanden und auch das wasserstoffgas
zwischen den galaxien richtet sich
entlang dieses netzwerkes aus doch es
war den fachleuten weltweit bislang
unmöglich es zu beobachten denn es
leuchtet nur schwach da es zehn bis
zwölf milliarden lichtjahre von der erde
entfernt ist doch klar ist auch diese
großräumige verteilung der materie im
universum als eine art netzwerk ist für
die forschung absolut super spannend sie
gilt als eine der wichtigsten
erkenntnisse der modelle zur kosmischen
strukturbildung warum diese filamente
außerdem so spannend für die fachwelt
sind hatte erst vor kurzem eine studie
gezeigt denn hier in den riesigen räumen
zwischen galaxienhaufen und galaxien
hellt sich nach ansicht vieler fachleute
wahrscheinlich die sogenannte verlorene
materie versteckt wir hatten ja darüber
berichtet theoretischen berechnungen
zufolge könnte sich hier in diesem
gespinst sogar mehr als die hälfte der
gesamten bayerischen material finden
also der materie die wir kennen doch
bislang gelang es nicht dies sichtbar zu
machen mit hilfe von rosita konnte das
deutsche forschungszentrum besonders
großen objekten wie eben die
den intergalaktischen filamenten machen
möglicherweise hält sich hier also die
gewöhnliche materie auf die fachleute
als die sogenannte bionische materie
bezeichnen zwar gibt es relativ
fundierter annahmen darüber wie viel
sich von dieser sogenannten barrio nisch
materie sich seit dem urknall in unserem
universum verteilt haben müssten doch es
gibt wohl weitaus mehr dieser normalen
materie als wir bislang mit den mitteln
die der wissenschaft zur verfügung
stehen wirklich nachweisen konnten die
fachleute sind diesem rätsel weiter auf
der spur feststehen aber bereits jetzt
die existenz dieses kosmischen netzes
bestätigt die wissenschaft in ihrem
wichtigsten vorhersagen darüber wie sich
die struktur des universums im laufe der
jahrmilliarden verändert hat aufnahmen
von diesem netz filamenten waren in der
vergangenheit jedoch nicht möglich doch
forschungsteams weltweit haben intensiv
an dieser herausforderung getüftelt denn
durch detailreiche aufnahmen dieser
strukturen wäre eine zeitreise der
besonderen art an die frühen anfänge
unseres universums möglich und genau das
ist einem internationalen gastronomie
team gelungen
vor 40 jahren schon hatten fachleute
hinweise darauf gefunden dass das
wasserstoffgas des kosmischen netzwerkes
aus sich heraus leuchten sollte
allerdings nur ganz schwach und so
gelang es bislang nur bruchstücke des
kosmischen netzes zu sehen und das auch
nur in der nähe von hellen fassaden
dabei handelt es sich ja um die zentren
von aktiven galaxien und bis heute haben
wir mehrere tausend solcher quasare
entdeckt es sind hat tatsächlich die
hellsten bekannten objekte in unserem
kosmos das muss man sich mal vorstellen
sie strahlen im sichtbaren licht mit
einer leuchtkraft die bis zu zehn hoch
14 mal größer ist als die der sonne und
so ist es kein wunder dass deren
intensive strahlung das lichtsignal des
gases enorm verstärkt bereits vor sechs
jahren 2014 gelang so auch die erste
direkte aufnahme der großräumigen gas
federman strukturen im alb dabei nutzte
das forschungsziel damals den umstand
dass krawalle wie kosmische scheinwerfer
wirken und nahegelegene gaswolken
anstrahlen so kommt es zu dem effekt der
auch das gas in einer leuchtstoffröhre
zum leuchten anregt fachleute sprechen
hier von der sogenannten fluoreszenz bei
einer leuchtstofflampe
wird die benötigte energie vom
elektrischen strom geliefert bei dieser
untersuchung war das intensive licht des
quasars qm2 87 dafür verantwortlich dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam im jahr 2014
das licht eines solchen casas gleicht
den strahl eines scheinwerfers in
unserem fall haben wir das glück dass
dieser scheinwerfer direkt auf ein
element des kosmischen netzwerkes
gerichtet ist und dessen gas zum
leuchten bringen doch das problem dabei
die hellen quasare liegen in dem sehr
dichten und seltenen regionen des
kosmischen netzes an den knotenpunkten
quasi und die sind alles andere als
repräsentativ für die umgebung normaler
galaxien und so kam es dass trotz
intensiver forschung das leuchtende gas
aus den eigentlichen kosmischen
filamenten bis heute nicht beobachtet
werden konnte doch jetzt der durchbruch
und zwar mit der hilfe eines neuen
instruments sein name multi unit
spektroskopie explorer kurznews ein
großteleskop der europäischen
südsternwarte in chile um also die bis
dann kaum untersuchten bereiche genauer
ins visier zu nehmen hatten die
fachleute insgesamt 140 stunden lang
einen kleinen bestimmten ausschnitt des
himmels beobachtet es handelt sich um
die himmelsregion mit dem namen habe als
rapid viel tratschen
die galaxien in diesem feld sind bis zu
13 milliarden lichtjahre entfernt es
gibt ein unglaubliches bild davon und
dieser ausschnitt wurde bislang bereits
eben vom hubble weltraumteleskop eine
lange zeit beobachtet und das ergebnis
ist ein bild mit unzähligen galaxien
doch die aktuellen aufnahmen sind nach
ansicht des beteiligten forschungsteams
noch mal eine nummer besser ihre
aufnahmen hätten die das hubble-teleskop
sogar zitat entthront so die forschenden
so wurde tatsächlich eine spannende
zeitreise mit hilfe von hughes möglich
denn klar ist je weiter einer galaxie
entfernt ist desto näher liegt sie
zeitlich auch am beginn des universums
die gas filamente die in der aktuellen
studie endlich kartiert werden wollten
entstanden somit also bereits ein bis
zwei milliarden jahre nach dem urknall
und das beschert den fachleuten super
spannende erkenntnisse
denn der 3d news spektrograph vom very
large telescope der europäischen
südsternwarte in chile offenbarte
dass sich in dem vergleichsweise kleinen
feld eine beeindruckend große zahl von
galaxien befindet dazu der astronom
wolfram klatschen die vom institut für
astrophysik der universität göttingen
der an der studie beteiligt war
es waren 100 mal mehr galaxien als man
üblicherweise bei klassischen
himmelsdurchmusterung findet 40 prozent
von ihnen waren so extrem leicht schwach
dass sie nicht einmal mit dem
hubble-teleskop entdeckt worden sind
möglich wurde diese entdeckung erst
durch den enormen technischen
fortschritt news wurde mit einer
zusätzlichen bildverbesserung versehen
die die fachleute als adaptive optik
bezeichnen so konnte - für 140 stunden
lange belichtung auf einen einzigen
fleck des hubble alter gibt fehlt
genutzt werden laut der forscherinnen
und forscher handelt es sich hierbei um
zitat die tiefste spektrale beobachtung
die jemals durchgeführt wurde und zwar
unter verwendung des fortschrittlichsten
spektroskopischen instrument der welt
und die ganze arbeit hat sich gelohnt
denn so konnten mehr als 2000 galaxien
aufgespürt werden von denen ein großteil
bei den klassischen galaxien
durchmusterungen nicht entdeckt werden
konnte
selbst bei den bildern des
hubble-weltraumteleskops sind die nun
neu aufgestellten galaxien völlig
unsichtbar
das muss man sich mal vorstellen denn
eigentlich hat habe diese region so tief
abgesucht wie keine andere region am
himmel die aktuellen beobachtung ließ es
nun also erstmalig zu karten von den
kosmischen netzfehler menton im jungen
universum zu erstellen und dabei stieß
das forschungsteam auf etwas was selbst
die fachleute überrascht dass scheinbar
diffuse licht der filamente kommt wohl
von einem ozean aus ultra schwachen
galaxien das ist wirklich der absolute
wahnsinn
diese sind zwar einzeln nicht zu sehen
erzeugen aber zusammen ein ausgedehntes
diffus wirkendes leuchten dazu sagt das
forschungsteam das hat uns wirklich
überrascht
es sieht so aus als ob es viel weniger
gas gibt das den fast leeren raum
zwischen den galaxien ausfüllt als wir
erwartet haben andererseits sehen wir
jetzt vielleicht zum ersten mal das
kollektive licht von winzigen klumpen
neu entstandener sterne im frühen
universum die sich dann später im laufe
der kosmischen zeit zu echten galaxien
endlich
was also steckt wirklich hinter dieser
filament artigen emission was ist der
ursprung und was verrät sie uns über die
entstehung von galaxien und deren
wechselwirkung mit ihrer umgebung klar
ist jedenfalls die direkte beobachtung
und rekordverdächtige aufnahme des
kosmischen netzes bestätigt die
vorhersage der wissenschaft zur
großräumigen materie verteilung und
entwicklung des universums hierbei geht
man von einer homogenen verteilung des
gases etwa 400.000 jahre nach dem
urknall aus für die kommenden jahre
peilen die fachleute nun weitere
fortschritte in der erforschung des
jungen universums an
so soll unter anderem das kosmische netz
im fernen weltall genauer
charakterisiert werden dabei könnte das
blue news instrument helfen dass bis
2030 in betrieb genommen werden soll
dabei handelt es sich um einen optischen
integral feld spektrografen mit
mittlerer spektrale auflösung das news
instrument wird er ergänzen weil er auf
den blauen spektralbereich optimiert
wird das ist also der tiefste blick den
wir je ins all gebrochen haben und wir
können demnächst eben noch tiefer
vordringen wo verschwundene materie
gefunden durch deutsches
weltraumteleskop da haben wir bereits
über die verschwundenen bionische
materie berichtet also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
der vater noch mehr über das phänomen
und natürlich diesen kanal klick
substanzen future abonnieren nicht
vergessen und ansonsten bis dann bleib
dran